happy saint patty's day to everybody so
if you got a small
buddy or whatever or even just somebody
who's uh loves alcohol
or just likes green lipstick or anything
you know if you like somebody
you know a lot of people smoke crack on
st patrick's day and it has nothing to
do with being irish or anything or
nothing
about luck so whatever went to the saint
patrick's day parade yesterday
that [ __ ] was disorganized to say the
least
i love new orleans but i do not like
that parade yesterday
i mean it was so irish dude it was
it was so it was so it was almost
scottish that's how bad it was dude it
was
pretty close to scottish the scottish
people are about the realest people in
the game dude
i mean they are they're thugs man
they're beautiful thugs man they are
beautiful
they are just the forgotten children
of the universe they still fight with
swords
you could be at a hospital in scotland
easily a couple dudes show up with
uh wounds from uh ordinary sword wounds
he'd be like what kind of sword did you
get hit with then he's like oh just a
ordinary sword dude those people are
still
just fighting each other with fire um
biting
a lot of people biting each other there
uh that's the kind of place where you
still get bit dude you got to be on your
bike game
st paddy's day if you want to
it's like the one day a year as a man if
you aren't gay that you could be gay
i never seen so many dudes and i think i
talked about this last name patrick's
day
kissing each other just because they got
a green shirt on
it's like oh hey you know like men just
dr drink it all that day drink and make
you kiss another man
and everybody's saying no but
everybody's thinking well maybe
and especially st patrick's day
everybody got a shirt kiss me i'm irish
and i saw i saw at least
20 men you know 10 pairs of two men
you know 40 lips just hit each other
head on
just had that head-on collision of of of
lips
and they were just all in the name of
ireland i guess
and alcoholism people wearing kilts men
wearing skirts
showing up wearing beads and skirts
kissing other men
because everybody's irish all of a
sudden
you know and so that's the gateway i
mean that's if you want to be gay you
know
how irish do you want to get you want to
duck off over here
behind this subaru and [ __ ] touch
each other's warm kneecaps
how iris you want to get because i saw
some adult men with families
getting real irish you know what i'm
talking i'm talking about
behind the shone he's kind of irish
because when i was young they would have
a lot of straight men would meet up
behind the shonies
and you know jerk each other off and do
stuff like that and then go back to
their families
because when i was young you couldn't
just you know it wasn't as
people who were gay couldn't openly be
gay
and you know i think about that struggle
sometimes or what that could you imagine
being something and not being able to be
it
that's i mean it's just i i couldn't
imagine what that you know that pain of
that
but then there was probably for a lot of
gay men there was that one day
oh here it comes put it on the calendar
march 17th
when all i gotta do is put on a green
shirt and i can gay the [ __ ] out
without any judgment now then look man i
saw it in tacoma you think they
are in spokane you think these men out
there they hard heads and they living
like this and that
they got three and four children but
they see they
suddenly they see another man who's
looking hell irish
and all of a sudden i saw these two men
just kiss face to face
and they could have been family that's
another thing you got a hot cousin
you think your stepdad is cute it's
march 17th
[ __ ] slide them a note check yes or
no papa
you know this that's the day it should
just be the day where you
anything goes that's what they should
start calling it
you know let's get irish you know what
i'm saying
if you're a lady and you want to you
know you want to touch somebody up in
the vulva do your thing
do that digit dance you know get your
carpels out
get your carpels out and go through that
brief filing cabinet
do a little bit of agiling you know what
i'm saying boy they only got two folders
in that cabinet boo boo
but people are getting hella irish man
and
you know and it's a joyous day and
that's one thing you know i don't drink
right now in my life and that's one
thing i miss is uh
i do miss some day drinking because
anything could happen when you're day
drinking
somebody jerk you off in a truck you
jerk yourself off somewhere
it's daytime you know it's like the
wolves are out it's like full
it's almost like a full moon but all day
long
and that's what always saint patty's was
for me
that's what saint patty's was for me man
it was fun eating chowder and drinking
beer and
people puking adults crying
man i saw i saw this one lady she was
probably 37.
just you know when you're crying so much
and she was trying to eat some what did
she have a bag of um
what are those chips those um
they are like these little hats these
chips they look like little bitty hats
like you could put them on your finger
and make five little hats
or if they had a gnome and he was
wearing like a little corn hat
you know or a dunce you know like if
someone if
these have these dunce hats they were
real tall v-neck looking hats upside
down
vs you know hats and
if you were like a dunce that would make
you wear this dunce hat but these little
what are they bugles bugles chips
and this lady had a sack of bugles and i
don't know if you ever had these bugles
chips but they they're
they absorb all the moisture in your
mouth so they dry you out
and this [ __ ] she was on
she was on some i mean she was making
salt water
she was making salt water up there she
was just salinating out of her face
just just wasted and crying and that's
something i love to see on the same path
i mean i don't want to you know i don't
want that lady to have this pain or
whatever she's going through but it's
alcohol induced
you know she had on that big pink
lipstick and all these different
necklaces you know kiss me i'm irish
[ __ ] me i'm irish you know
uh help me raise my kids i'm irish i
mean she was getting out there
extensively with some of her ideas
you know based on the on the country on
this on this little island
of britain or ireland i don't know if
it's an island i don't know
ireland island i could easily see
somebody
get confused and think they live in
jamaica but everybody's white
you know but um but yeah this lady was
bursting
she was just just crying just
drunk crying and trying to eat these
bugles at the same time
i mean at one po at one point i swear
she was kind of dipping the bugles in
her tears
so she would have enough moisture to get
them bugles down her
you know down her gullet to gull at them
bugles
and that was you know that spokane baby
people set it off and people came out we
had a great time man we had a great time
over there in spokane
but yeah if you i think i you know we
should just say st patty's day is the
one day
where if you're trying to bust a nut on
somebody that's got the same genitalia
as you
then you gone because to me it gets
more and more it's not really green it's
more a little more it's got a little
more rainbow in it
and you you'd see a lot of gay men i
remember last year in new orleans
i was doing st patrick's day down there
with two of my good buddies and
you would see a lot of me a lot of gay
men out there
you know trying to dress real straight
you know wearing like um
you know beavis and butt head t-shirts
or
um you know wearing um
you know wearing uh you know not
turtlenecks you know not looking real
gay or wearing like a kind of gay attire
and i know that you know that's kind of
a generalization i'm not trying to say
gay people look one way or whatever but
you know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
you know if you had if you had if you
put a tracker on all the turtlenecks in
america
most of them would end up on probably
most of those trackers would lead you to
the homes of gay men
or italians probably
you know or male librarians so i'm just
i'm playing the odds here
but they had a lot of um you know you'd
see a lot of these men trying to look
real straight you know
wearing like nascar t-shirts and [ __ ]
but also with the irish beads i'm irish
just trying to freaking lock just trying
to lock lips with some straight men
who are out there letting their feelings
loose
you know and that's how it happens next
thing you know boy
next thing you know your leg hair is all
tangled up with another man's leg hair
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one